houston I understand you attended law
school I did okay and when you came to
LA was your focus to become an attorney
no it actually wasn't that was the the
main reason I came to LA is so I
wouldn't become an attorney and I went
to law school in Virginia and at a great
law school and I really loved the
experience and did really well my focus
was on entertainment law and litigation
at the same University where I went to
law school there was a film school as
well and so naturally given the the
subject matter of my study which was
film law and entertainment law I became
friends with a number of film students
at the same University started writing
and producing content on the side of law
school and all the spare time you have
in law school and then just kind of got
bit by the bug and really started to
drill down in that last semester of law
school you know what exactly do I want
to do with the rest of my life is it you
know cuz I'm very much a you know I
would have I want to pursue work that
doesn't feel like work and if I could
you know if money was no option I could
do anything I wanted to do would it be
going into the law office every day it's
gonna be in going to a courtroom every
day and it wasn't that I was more
attractive to the other side of the
transaction on the entertainment side of
things so luckily the the Juris Doctor
degree is very versatile and so I knew I
could use it to pursue entertainment as
a producer as an agent as whatever I
wanted to do when I got out here and you
know at least that's what I told my
mother-in-law so as though it wasn't a
big waste of time but but yeah so so
once I graduated law school in Virginia
pursued a couple opportunities there but
we really made the decision to to really
move out here so we ten years ago just
packed up our Jetta sold everything we
had and just came out here so I've been
here ever since it's been great once you
came to Los Angeles you probably saw
that a lot of people that had chosen the
artists path it was a little trickier to
actually you know
for the family how did you decide to
incorporate you know your knowledge of
contract law and all these other things
with the creative what's interesting
because the biggest thing with with law
school is law school doesn't really it's
not all about teaching you the law the
biggest thing for me with law school was
that it it teaches you how to think and
it just rearranges your brain in such a
way that you can now approach any
problem and really be able to
deconstruct it in a different way to
find an eventual solution and so when I
got out here it was you know I didn't go
to film school and so now I needed to
figure out how to break in just like the
you know hundred thousand other people
that do that every month and but I
looked at the problem of breaking in and
in a different way I think I was
thinking about it differently because
the line of screenwriters that are very
talented the line of directors that are
very talented those lines are very long
and it's very competitive
they're all trying to go through a
couple different doors and for me I
wanted to try to figure out how to
differentiate myself in the marketplace
find a different door insight into the
industry and and I come from a really
interesting varied background where you
know I was I was a heavy creative writer
in in high school I played a lot of
tabletop role-playing games like
Dungeons & Dragons but not dungeons
dragons things like that they when I was
in college I wrote for the stage a lot I
invented board games to sell off the
licensers and manufacturers just through
this bizarre hobby then once I got into
law school obviously I had my my legal
training but also wrote and produced for
the screen while I was in law school so
I so understand in sort of these bizarre
skill sets that I have
I wanted to figure out how to leverage
all those things to help differentiate
myself in the marketplace to try to find
a different way in I quickly hooked up
with a couple people once I was out here
one guy that a comic book and a
technology background another guy that
had a music background he had 20 years
in the music industry and another guy
that had this branding and marketing
background so we all sitting around the
table working on a pilot project and we
thought okay how do I
we use all these other things that we
have as a way to help leverage our
project in a different way how do we
create this this pilot but at the same
time incorporate a boardgame
component incorporate some technology or
a comic component how do we approach it
in a brand building way rather than
entertainment way and it was really for
this fascinating subject for me and it
was a fascinating problem to try to
solve once we started trying to do that
then that kind of got me to into the
area of transmedia
but I don't think I would have done
could have done that if I hadn't
analyzed the problem differently from a
legal perspective because if there's
there's you know the industry is is
wildly complicated but at the same time
it's very similar to the way it's been
run for the last 50 hundred years and so
for me just sitting back coming in
completely fresh eyes I looked at the
way the industry was built and the way
it was constructed and a lot of it
didn't make sense then a lot of the the
path that most people were taken seemed
to be not a logical path because it was
a wreck running a headlong into the
problems rather than trying a different
path to solve the problem
Einstein always said that you can't you
can't solve a problem with the same
thinking that caused it and so so I
looked at the problem looked at it
differently and thought we could take a
different path and so so that that got
me to where I am now which is using all
the tools that are disposal all the
mediums and platforms that all our
disposal in order to try to attack the
the industry in a completely different
way so where most people attack sort of
the industry from a right-brain creative
yeah you were coming from this left
brain sort of analytical critical
thinking sure interesting so that's
that's where you said you they sort of
taught you a different way around it
yeah whereas the long line was thinking
from this right brain well if I create
this amazing story it doesn't matter
I'll be let in yeah exactly and that's
it you know and it it's interesting
because I'm not even once
I don't even wanna say that's that's the
wrong way because
it's the more competitive way and so for
me you know you could have it you can
have a lemonade stand in a neighborhood
and it'd be great but if there's a
hundred other lemonade stands that pop
up in your same neighborhood you have to
start looking at how you approach your
business differently it's not just make
how to make better lemonade like because
there's a certain point it's really
difficult to make better lemonade right
I mean and all these other people making
lemonade are gonna try to be trying to
make better lemonade and then it just
becomes very very difficult to try to
stand out in the lemonade business when
there's so many people trying to make
lemonade and so it's not just the
quality that has to improve which that
that's sort of a given we you also have
to just approach the the business of it
from a different way in order to
separate yourself in the marketplace
most people we most people say if I
can't make better lemonade then I'm just
gonna do something else which I don't
think is a I don't think is the answer
because if if God puts you on earth to
make lemonade you make lemonade if
you're supposed to be a screenwriter
you'd be a screenwriter but you have to
approach it differently in order to be
competitive I know you're about to
release your second book but I wanted to
ask you about your first book church was
was that in 2013 2013 released make your
story really stinking big through Mike
Alesi productions and it was funny
because when I got to LA I was I didn't
go to film school so I had to self
educate myself and so Michael we see
productions like I loved their line of
film books primarily because or at least
initially because they had the best
covers and I'm like a graphic design guy
so I like like nice cool covers I was
attracted to the line of books and loved
her line of books and then when I
decided to publish my book I I was going
to self publish it but just decided on a
whim to send it to them and they ended
up picking it up right away and
published through them so that was kind
of cool but yeah that was 2013 release
okay and so where were you in your life
when you decided to write it and where
would you find the spare time sure so
when I first decided to write that book
was we were we were really me and me and
my team and the guys I was hooked up
with we're trying to figure out how to
best tell stories that touched multiple
mediums and multiple platforms how do we
extend the story across the multitude of
mediums in a way where it all works
together from news to form a new
experience with the audience and and I
actually you know I was I I didn't
realize it at the time but I brought
some of this with me even from law
school I I produced a I produced a film
while I was in law school and it was
this just a you know it's like a 25
minute short and I as the film was being
produced I wrote and produced I didn't
direct it and as it was being produced I
had an original song produced
simultaneously for the film what was
interesting about the film was that the
protagonist of the film only has a
couple lines during the the entire film
is very he doesn't speak hardly at all
he's very much like just it's internally
kind of a guy so for the song when I was
working with the songwriter for the song
I thought well this was gonna be a great
way to get inside the characters head so
now the song is gonna release these
internal thoughts that you don't hear
obviously or know about when you watch
the movie so now the song and the movie
will go together in this really
interesting way then I thought you know
be really cool when we do the music
video if we can use the same sets that
you know as we're produced in the film
we can just either before we we film a
scene or after we film a scene before we
strike we can just put the musician in
there film the the music video send that
then it's the same looking aesthetic as
the as the movie then I thought would be
kind of cool is if we had the actors
also in the scenes as well it's like if
they were blocking a scene then we could
have you know them in there and that
kind of give it it's interesting look
and then I thought okay well if we can
shoot the entire scene the scenes from
the movie maybe from a different angle
in the music video when you watch the
music video you're going to get new
information that you don't get from the
movie so now when you watch the music
video and the movie together it's going
to give you this full thing made my
director go crazy as you
can imagine but I brought that type of
thinking with me out here you know I
grew up very much into Star Wars he-man
GI Joe transformers these multi-platform
projects and so I I've always had a sort
of a taste for that so when we got here
and I tried to do it it was very
difficult it you would think okay coming
up with a board game thing come up with
a mobile game an app a comic book that
I'll tie in together wouldn't wouldn't
be that hard but to have it to do that
well is very difficult and we failed a
couple times and we learned a lot of
lessons so I put I hit the pause button
and went on about a two-year research
project looking in every great
multi-platform project that I could find
every very poor multi-platform project I
could find and again used my lawyer
super abilities to forensic ly audit the
creative choices that they made the
business choices that made why did the
Goodwin succeed why did the bad ones
fail and I was looking for me just a
creative rubric to of how to move
forward for me just for me and you know
and being the genius that I am I decided
to do all the things like the good ones
did and not do the ones that the bad
ones did
and so I formed a creative process I
guess a creative rubric that that she
was just really for me and my own
projects and the team's projects but I
decided hey this would be kind of a cool
book again I'm trying to figure out how
to differentiate myself in the in the
marketplace
from all the other competitive people
and I thought if I've created something
that works for me
other people that are trying to solve
this problem would benefit from this and
so that's when I published the book so
so you know at the same time I was you
know I was doing legal consulting while
I was out here I was working with not as
a lawyer but with lawyers and how to
best present their best presented their
arguments to a jury how to incorporate
more storytelling how to incorporate
diamond dynamic visuals things like that
and basically trying to help like
produce their courtroom performance in
an interesting way while I was doing
that I was writing the book
and then when I wrote the book really
all I wanted to be was a business like a
big fat business card for me but once
the book was released then other people
started calling me who read the book
like Mattel called me and said hey we
read your book we want you to come in
and talk about a project the Disney
Imagineers hey hey we you know we want
you to come talk about which is
something I never considered I was just
doing this for me and my own projects
but that could sort of opened opened me
up to so there's a whole of the realm of
of work which was great when you're
stuck in a full-time job have other
options that are closer to where you
want to be is always exciting and new
and different then working with other
people on their projects help me on my
own projects because then you just start
to build a facility of diagnosing
problems coming up with quick
prescriptions for those problems and you
kind of sharpen that tool so then when
you get your own projects it's very
efficient something you said triggered a
question I have further down but I'll
bump it up and that was you were talking
about the music video of the film that
you made while you were in law school
and then I saw a video that you did
where you say when a book turns into a
film that a game and then a comic book
that's not transmedia it's multimedia so
can we talk about how many people think
that that is transmedia and and dispel
some of the myths yeah so the you know
especially in the 80s we had this boom
of the multimedia franchise and
multimedia is is the same story that's
adapted across multiple mediums you know
the the book becomes the movie that
movie becomes the the graphic novel that
graphic novel becomes the video game
it's basically the same story and the
same plot over and over and over again
just Express Express through multiple
mediums transmedia is sort of this
second cousin of that and where instead
of having the Twilight books become the
Twilight movie that becomes a Twilight
videogame that becomes the Twilight
graphic novel now we have the books that
then set up the movie that then lead
into the graphic novel that then
culminates in the videogame all the
different
touchpoints tell a different completely
different story but in a way to where
all the stories work together to tell
one big story and that's that's a
different process but it was it was
birthed out of the the necessity of of
the marketplace and now that you know in
you have grown up in the 80s and the 90s
the multimedia franchise was fine
because there you know what else are you
going to do we didn't have the 8,000
different entertainment options that we
have today it was real imited and so you
were consumers and audiences were okay
with just experiencing the same story
over and over and over again because
there were very limited amounts of
options today we now have you know 8,000
television channels we have cable
satellite network Netflix Hulu Amazon we
have millions of YouTube videos we have
access to every TV show ever made every
movie ever produced every book ever
written we have millions of mobile games
that are available just in our pocket
anytime we want and so now when we can
entertain ourselves with anything that
we want the marketplace has been going
for new stuff rather than repurpose
content so if you give a consumer the
option of a video game where you already
know the story and a video game that you
don't know the story now they're opting
for the new story they're opting for the
new book they're opting for the new
movie because they just don't want to
repurpose the same thing over and over
and over again so when the audience is
now demand new new new you you have to
figure out how to continually give them
new story rather than repurpose story
which then has created this really
interesting opportunity in the
marketplace but at the same time
obstacle in the marketplace because now
we have to figure out how to continually
tell new stories because the multi media
franchise just isn't performing the way
it used to perform and so so in just
like any good in a good capitalistic
system the market is the one that that
pushes toward change and that's what
we've seen over the past in you
we can see how transmedia would work for
million-dollar sort of ad campaign but
for a low-budget film for somebody
that's an independent filmmaker may be
working with a six-figure budget how can
they incorporate transmedia
it seems like it's almost out of the
picture for them and you would think I
mean this is this I think this is one of
the biggest misconceptions of transmedia
is that we you know and partly it's it's
it's my fault because I talk about large
projects Star Wars you know Harry Potter
your things like this we look toward
though all the Marvel stuff that's going
on now the way they design their
projects is tremendous for the audience
experience and the only reason that they
do that the only reason that these
projects are rolling out the way they
are rolling out is because the market
has an appetite for it so so they're
proving the fact that the audience wants
that type of a project something that
that is a never go dark experience so
after the movie I still should be able
to go home and to experience more
stories somewhere else after the you
know between episodes of the TV show I
should be able to engage online with
some sort of added content but this is
what the market wants so we can
establish that but again how do how do
how does an indie filmmaker how do that
if they don't have you know a billion
dollars at their disposal in my
perspective it's all about how do we use
the principles of George Lucas how do we
use the principles of Marvel how do we
use the principles of Harry Potter and
apply them to to our project our smaller
project or independent project that's
what fascinates me I think most about
about this because the the law of
gravity does it say the law lift the law
lift over overcomes the law of gravity
in order to make an airplane fly you
look at a 777 that picks up off the off
the ground and flies into the sky you
you don't say well I have to have a 777
in order to fly you know yeah
you could have a smaller plane and if
you understand the law lift and the law
gravity and how those work together if
you just understand those principles
your tiny little plane can fly just as
much as the the big 777 you may have to
gas up more times you mean it may not be
able to go as far but you can still get
in the air and so so that's the way I
look at it I look at you know star wars
of the 777 but if this star wars is
proving to us what the law lifts of what
the law of gravity can do let's take
those laws and apply them to our own
project because I think is actually more
necessary for an independent project to
be able to or an independent producer
and independent screenwriter to be able
to understand the multi-platform world
in a transmedia world and what I call
super story model if we're because they
don't have the P&A budgets that's what
it really breaks down to the three
hundred thousand dollar picture the
hundred thousand dollar picture they're
not gonna have the thirty five million
dollar P&A budget they're not gonna have
the 70 million dollars a PNA to be able
to let everybody know who they are what
their project is and why they should
support it so they have to approach the
marketplace differently again the the if
the lemonade stand analogy if there's a
thousand other lemonade stands not only
a thousand other eliminates ants but a
thousand other lemonade enterprises that
are much bigger and more expensive and
they have better lemons and more money
to spend you have to figure out a
different way because you don't have the
same you know the same resources and so
if you look at how you advertise you
know it's to get one commercial on one
time for 30 seconds on Fox in primetime
three hundred fifty thousand dollars
just for the not just the production
budget of the of the commercial just for
the 30-second hole to display one one
commercial one time so usually
independent filmmakers don't have that
to spend or if they do what I say what
would happen if you did one less
commercial what would happen if you took
that three hundred fifty thousand
dollars and you would spend it on
something that that could actually give
your fans or people that that support
your project more content
and how do we differentiate ourselves in
the marketplace how do we spend the
money wiser and so you know for me I
look at something like moonlight
you know before moonlight won an Oscar
it it very few people saw it and
moonlights a great film but if you look
at the box-office before it won the
Oscar and the box office after won an
Oscar it's very different it was only
only a few theaters made a few that
100th out you know hundred thousand
dollars or so then after when the Oscar
got out the wide release but you can't
as an independent producer you can't
build a business plan around winning an
Oscar all I've got to do is win an Oscar
then we're good so you gotta approach
the marketplace differently and so so
for me it I'll take I want to look at an
independent project and say okay this in
the print project how can I begin to
seed interest and awareness and develop
pre awareness before my movie comes out
so the two years that it takes to even
produce a film in a release of film you
could be already building pre awareness
for it through things like self
publishing a novel you can release
interesting digital content you can give
all your characters in your in your
script Twitter accounts and as if they
were real people and go ahead and start
seeding storylines and create
interaction between the months before
the film that is ever released you can
you can go after different markets and
create music content that may give you
access to a different target market than
the main target market of your movie and
none of that you can do some of these
things that can actually start
generating revenue well ahead of the
release of the film so so for me the
that is a much better spend than a
single commercial that you would spend
on the back end and that gives that
gives your fan base now more content to
dig into and gives you a separation of
the marketplace from all the other
independent films that are being
released so so you know if you look at
if you look at if you look at programs
like AMC independent where the you know
you can go directly to the exhibitor
what
bypassing the distributor which is a
great program the way they choose which
which projects to put into their AMC
Indy program is how how are you going to
build awareness for your campaign or for
your film how are you going to let
people know that you're that you're
there because you're not going to have
the distributor paying for the PA so so
now you have to have that mechanism to
build pre awareness but what's cool is
after you that's architectures out there
any fans that go into the film that
haven't seen all the stuff that you've
done even to build pretty good wareness
they now can go back flow backwards and
access it and now it's extended content
for them so now after I see the
moonlight movie I can go read the
moonlight novel that's a continuation of
it I can then go dig into the into the
comic books they see new storylines
there's a you can use a book of poetry
that gives you insight into it a whole
different character lots of stuff that
you can do understanding the principles
of the big guy but be able to apply it
to your independent project in a way
that gives you that separation and
advantage of the marketplace that's
excellent let me just make sure I
understand it because I still have
trouble you know wrapping my mind around
the concept of transmedia
so it's like building bridges if we're
using this architectural sort of analogy
it's building bridges it's not repeating
the same story over and okay
exactly yeah we you know for me I never
want to tell the same story twice that
that's what my goal is I go into a
transmedia project I never want to tell
the same story twice because the thing
that fans love the most the most more
than anything is new story and you know
I just recently benched
all six seasons of Game of Thrones and
after six seasons in a in a month all I
wanted was more story and I was
searching for more story and searching
for more story I thought about going and
reading the books but I knew the books
would pretty much tell me the same story
and so I wanted new stuff that's what I
wanted most of all and so that's what
that's what fans want you know when I
was it when I was a kid my mom bought me
I was a Star Wars fan and my mom bought
me the novelization of the original
trilogy which was great in the inning
in the early 90s there wasn't a lot of
stuff out there I was a good I was a
heavy reader so she got me the book I
read it it was good it was the same
story in both places and so it was okay
but in the Empire Strikes Back there's a
scene in the Empire Strikes Back
that where Darth Vader is talking to a
group of bounty hunters and he tells
them all to go out and catch han Solo
Boba Fett is the only one who does and
you never see all those other bounty
hunters again one day my mom bought me a
different book called the tales of the
bounty hunters which was the short story
anthology following all those other
bounty hunters and their adventure
trying to catch Han Solo and ultimately
how they failed for me when I read that
as a kid it was revelatory because it
was new Star Wars stuff like it wasn't
the same set it was new Star Wars stuff
which was awesome I like completely
devoured that book in a couple days
because it was new and and for the
filmmakers it was a great way one to
generate new revenue to to continually
engage an audience in new stuff without
having to shoot another movie so it for
filmmakers if the filmmakers only think
the way to tell stories is through
movies then they won't tell that many
stories because it's very as you know
it's very expensive and difficult to be
able to shoot movies all the time and so
even if you spend the rest of your life
making movies and you never stop there's
gonna be two year gaps you know it mean
it's gonna be when you go into
development pre-production production
post-production distribution it's a
two-year cycle to be able to get a movie
out into the market and so if all you
did is make movies there's gonna be
two-year gaps where you're not engaging
fanbase so now in in this oversaturated
world of entertainment not engaging your
fans for two years two years is a
dangerous thing
and so and so now you have to figure out
different ways to engage them well how
do I do it if I can't make movies well
you do you use other things just as much
and so as you're making your movies
let's be feeding our fans new content
through all the things that we ever
owned at our disposal social media
content
I'm not talking about advertising
through social media I'm saying you know
how do we deliver content through social
media that extends the story in a
valuable way how do I use digital
content how do I use comic books
self-published novels music art you know
fine art you can do sculptures you can
do poetry you can do anything that can
tell a story stage plays TV whatever you
want all the options are out there that
one can give your audience more
engagement and more story which they
love more than more than anything else
and - it gives your investors more of an
opportunity to capture revenue and so
one of the biggest obstacles for for an
independent artist is how do you find
investment money how's the independent
investor look at your movie and find
that it's a good business model and and
what we've seen now is the investment
that the pools of investment money is
drying up rather quickly it's very
difficult to be able to go out and get
them the amount of money that we need to
create these films because the business
model doesn't make a lot of sense
anymore there's been too much disruption
in the marketplace it creates it costs
too much to advertise for a film
I mean Steven Soderbergh was just he
just had a an interview where he said
just to be a blip on the radar
now you have to have 35 billion dollars
of domestic PA 35 million dollars of
international PA just to be a blip on
the radar to let people know you there
because there's so much competitions too
many lemonade stands in the neighborhood
and which means that's 70 million
dollars of PA to recoup to recoup your
PA it's 50 cents on a dollar so all of a
sudden to recoup that 70 million dollars
a PA you have to make 140 million
dollars add in let's say let's say you
have a million dollar production budget
then it's 141 million dollar break-even
on a 1 million dollar picture so imagine
yourself as a businessman I go to I go
to you and say I say Karen will you
invest in my script for a million
dollars we can make this amazing film
together and all we have to do is make a
hundred and forty-one million and you
get all your money back
that doesn't make a lot of sense right
and so now people say well well well I
won't do any PNA then I'll just you know
don't go won't go through a distributor
and just self you know self distribute
or whatever that now if you don't have
if you don't have another plan of how to
build awareness for your project and
engage in audience it that's maybe even
more dangerous than the first routes or
you may you may say well I'll cut back
on the PA or off you know and it's just
a game of how far can I cut back and
still be able to survive so for me if we
can figure out a different way forward
to say to an event to go to an investor
and say here is how we're going to give
you a different business model here's
how we're going to give you an
opportunity to recoup faster and to coop
more and recoup over a longer period of
time and so now instead of just one
revenue stream that I can generate that
you can recoup which is the movie it's
going to be the main one now there was
gonna be four or five additional ways
that you can recoup and own to that as
we wait our two years before you start
recouping from the movie you'll be
recouping in these other two ways that
are gonna hit the marketplace a lot
earlier so you'll be recouping your your
investment well before the movie even
hits the market which is great and
instead of the two to five year window
that you'll have to recoup the bulk of
your investment from the film now we can
build it to where there's a 15 year
window because after the movie gets out
and it has its two-year window to
generate the revenue then we're gonna
release this and then we're gonna
release this and then we're going to
release this and that's going to bridge
the gap up until the time we maybe want
to release a different film and and
you're going to be a play a part of all
that
so here's product diversification we
have a product line diversification we
have multiple streams of revenue we're
hitting not just one or two markets now
we're going to hit seven markets for a
longer period of time when you start to
position yourselves like that now it
becomes a better business decision for
the investor which is better for the
independent producer because somebody
has to pay for your movie because then a
lot of people say to me well I'll just
do Kickstarter Kickstarter's the savior
of the independent of the
in a film you know 90% of films that are
on Kickstarter don't get funded at all
get $0 and it's so sad and and and and
it's just there's that much stuff out
there the 10% that do get funded get
funded and on an average of $12,000 and
to make it to make a career as a
independent filmmaker we can't we have
to we have our vision has to be greater
than 12,000 dollar movies listen if you
get 12,000 dollars to make a movie god
bless you that's awesome I'm not saying
I'm not I don't want to diminish that
accomplishment but it's but ultimately
we don't want to have to be baristas as
we as we make movies we don't want to
have to have our day job and shoot on
the weekends as you do the grind that's
awesome that's what you should do but we
need now a bigger vision and a better
business model to be able to have a new
way forward you know I like to say at
some point at some point well the
lightbulb wasn't invented by the
continuous improvement of the candle at
some point somebody had to say okay the
candles great
god bless the candle candles awesome but
we now need to kind of build a different
model to be able to get a bigger results
and so now we've seen independent films
being diminished in the marketplace and
and the answer to that isn't just
writing it better or shooting it better
of course you need to write it well and
shoot it well but we also need to build
a different architecture around it so it
can be sustainable and have an advantage
in the marketplace especially how we how
we communicate it to it to a an investor
I just had a filmmaker go to me for a he
had he wanted to raise $10,000 for a
short film it's all he wanted to do he
said do you think there's nothing
transmedia potential here I looked at it
and we we kind of worked together for
about a day and I kind of added a few
tricks to it and kind of built out the
IP and he went talked to this investor
who he was going for a $10,000
investment he walked away with a two
hundred and thirty thousand dollar
investment because all of a sudden it
the whole thing made more sense business
sense
right and so and so that now he was so
happy as independent filmmaker saying
now I can actually shoot my short shoot
these other things I actually can go
into pre-production on my feature my
investor can be beamed paid back based
on these other two things and now has an
equity stake in the feature film as we
move forward
etc etc and he was super excited and all
he's all we did is he's using the
principles of Star Wars the principles
of Harry Potter the principles of the of
Marvel and building that in to his
independent film business plan that
separates him in the marketplace Houston
I'm wonder if you could just define for
me prints and advertising PA what just
so I can fully understand sure PA prints
and advertising is the way is the way to
build awareness it's basically the
marketing for a film it's people don't
use prints as much anymore
the prints is being changed to more
digital stuff so so the a and P and a is
I think the the the large case a the
upper case a and the small P but it is
how a distributor builds awareness for
the film and make sure the film
everybody knows about the film and and
so that's great because because in an
oversaturated world you need to be able
to let people know that you exist I mean
today access access to people isn't an
issue it's not that's no longer a
problem
because of the internet I can shoot a
movie I can put on YouTube I can put on
Vimeo I can put on up on the Internet in
a hundred different ways and instantly
I'm in three billion people's pockets
around the world so now like access to
people is not an issue ever ever again
more likely and like that's not a
problem the problem is how do if I if my
movies in your pocket or in your purse
how do you know it's there and so that
that's really the biggest issue right
now and so they think well all we can do
is make sure we pump up our PA to have
these exorbitant P&A budgets and that's
the way to let people know that there
but in an era where people hate
advertising people hate marketing we we
invent technology just to skip ads and
I'm not I'm sure I'm not the only one
that putting on much in a YouTube video
and I'm there's an ad on before the
video I'm just staring at the bottom
right hand corner ready to click as soon
as it zero right like we're trained to
avoid advertising and so then when
everybody's trying to avoid advertising
the studio's say well we'll just do more
advertising will do more advertising
will do more advertising and is
oversaturate oversaturate say you can't
escape it but then people will always
try to escape it my my perspective is is
how do you engage them in different ways
and let's let's let's take the the the
purpose of PA which is building
awareness building pre awareness making
sure that there's a there's an audience
that is built to to show up on an
opening day or the first two weekends
how do we how do we accomplish that
through a more effective way because
it's not always about just throwing
money and after money after money after
money in some of these ineffective ways
it's about how do we think a little bit
differently and engage the marketplace
and a different way and what we know now
is people love story people love
entertainment people love characters we
live in an entertainment society and
everybody always talks about the
diminished attention span of people
today because there's so many options
you know ever heard someone to say
recently that people have a have lower
attention attention spans lower than a
goldfish right like you know cuz we're
there's so much stuff and that and
that's why people don't want to watch
advertising because we just we get
distracted too easily I don't
necessarily believe that because men get
what they're saying but the same people
that they say have attention spans lower
than that of a goldfish they'll binge
watch 10 hours of house of cards on the
one of the weekend that it's released
and so they can zero in and watch house
of cards for 10 hours on their couch
focused engaged they'll sit there and
binge watch you know 13 reasons why
they'll they'll rip
six seasons a Game of Thrones in a month
because of course you would I'll watch
all seven Star Wars movies back to back
to back to back to back to back to back
back up until episode 8 is released in
giant marathon we can focus we can
engage an ant but we can now choose what
we focus and engage in to and so all we
have to do is provide other mechanisms
for people to engage and if you can
provide other mechanisms that are
engaging then all of a sudden we can
accomplish the purpose of PA but in a
way that is more valuable for the
audience and even a way that can that
can even drive additional revenue so
that that's really what I'm that
fascinates me about this model is how
how we can attack how can we attack the
whole problem that's surrounding
independent filmmaking and and the
storytelling in general how are we just
going to attack it a different way
that's more rewarding for fans and more
rewarding for filmmakers you mentioned
briefly that binding production for an
independent film is harder these days
hasn't it always been difficult it
absolutely has always been difficult
it's never been easy but what's happened
is it's an already difficult task has
become more difficult because because to
really engage investors and business men
and business women you actually have to
make the whole the whole venture make
business sense now there they're always
going to be some investors that that
have discretionary disposable income
that you know can just believe in your
project and and dump money into it
whether or not they they get a they get
a return or not there's always going to
be that marginal group that you know hey
you put my granddaughter in your movie
then yeah I'll I'll put $100,000 in sure
you know and or they just like believe
in the purpose your project they'll dump
it in that that is a rarity and what we
have to do is we have to approach the
business of filmmaking from a
perspective of an investor and learn
what motivates an investor learn the
value propositions buy
and the business model so that they can
feel comfortable with with giving you
their you know their money that they've
worked very hard on or hard for and you
now once they give you your money you as
a filmmaker have what the quote I'll
give you a law school term is it's
called a fiduciary responsibility you
have a fiduciary responsibility which is
a legal and ethical responsibility to be
able to take care of that money take
care of the investment and do everything
that you can to get a return on that
investment and and so it's it's not a I
never take anybody that gives me money
lightly at all it's it's it's one of the
highest compliments and one of the the
biggest responsibilities that you have
as a filmmaker and so now you have to
you have in order to get that you have
to have the whole thing make business
sense so you have to imagine what what
motivates an investor it's it's probably
not your three-act structure it's
probably not your really amazing be
story plot it's not your interesting
subplots it's not your plot twists and
your act 3 it's how do you get them a
return on investment it's it's the
amount of ROI the return on investment
it's how long is this gonna be in the
marketplace is this short term
investment or is there is it a long term
investment
it's how big is the market that you're
trying to attack is it you know very
small or is it very large there's the
there's these things that we're trying
to that we have to try to figure out
filmmakers hate this stuff because
they're creatives right that's why
usually filmmakers need good you know
directors and writers need good
producers because producers can think
this way but what from my perspective is
if a creator if a if the writers and the
directors if you can be thinking this
way from the beginning then and approach
the creative decisions that you make in
your in your story in such a way that
optimizes your IP your script your
project
larger investment and larger revenue
potential all of a sudden that's the
best because you're not just leaving it
to the quote unquote bean counters to
figure out you're not leaving it to a
producer to sell the investment the
creative is optimized for the for the
investment for example going back to the
the the the the principles of George
George Lucas Darth Vader this the scene
in the Empire Strikes Back where Darth
Vader's talking to the bounty hunters
could have been between Darth Vader and
Boba Fett there didn't have to be any
other characters they're just Darth
Vader's saying Boba Fett go catch Han
Solo but Lucas made the creative
decision in the story to have Boba Fett
and eight other bounty hunters there in
that scene now what that did that
creative decision then spurred a whole
other product that was part of the
business plan which was this anthology
of short stories that existed in the
marketplace to engage the fan base and
generate revenue that all was was
promised and created and birthed out of
the creative decision of the writer and
director to have multiple characters in
the scene so so a lot of a lot of times
there's been this divide this this
thinking that there's a divide between
the creative and the business but if the
creative can understand the business and
create in a way that optimizes it
optimizes the project for the business
then there's so much more opportunity
out there because if it's not built
right creatively then that will maximize
or limit the type of business
opportunities that you have down the
road and so so if you can just build the
project right present it right to a to
an investor and it makes business sense
yeah I was talking to an investor in
Canada recently who yeah I I we were
part of a project and and I call him
he's this big-time angel investor he has
10,000 angel investors underneath him
and his network of angel investors guys
a big guy and I
I got on the phone with him he said hey
Houston I'm gonna give you I'm gonna
give you ten minutes and I said okay he
said I charge $10,000 an hour for my
business consultation I I don't speak
anywhere for less than $25,000 you know
per event and it's not fair to all those
people that pay all that money that I
give you a bunch of free time but
because we had a little bit of
relationship because we spoke at this a
similar event a few years prior he said
I'll give you ten minutes free and I
said okay he's the guy who's like
straight business guy right he I said
well I want to hear to talk to you about
this film project that we have going on
and he stopped me 90 seconds and he said
listen he said out of my 10,000 angel
investors I could probably only think of
four who would even consider investing
into entertainment at all and he said
it's just too risky
he said you probably if you get a return
you're gonna give a return for about a
year and a half after its release it's
just it's a difficult market and a
difficult invested investment to make
but maybe there's four and if everything
goes well you may be able to get a one
hundred fifty to one hundred thousand
dollars out of each of them so you know
we're looking at a you know two hundred
thousand two hundred two thousand dollar
investment if all goes really super well
and I said well I appreciate that but
really what we want to do is this isn't
just going to be a film project this is
gonna be what we call a super story it's
going to be at this large-scale
transmedia project that's going to have
you know all these different things as a
part of it and I sat there and talked to
him one for 90 minutes and and I'm start
talking about the different revenue
opportunities the different markets that
we're going to touch the different the
shelf life of the project how we're
going to build pre awareness while the
movie is going to be being produced how
we're gonna take some things that would
we're gonna shift some things in the
advertising budget to more content story
stuff that we can release simultaneous
to the film so wouldn't extend the
experience then we're gonna release
other things after the film that's gonna
bridge the gap to the next film and he
said he said to me he said in 30 years
em invest
no-one's ever approached me with an
entertainment pitch that is that has
sounded like this he said this sounds
like a franchisable business more so
than a dozen movie he said based on this
I think we could do two rounds of
financing I think we could do a 75
million dollar round of financing and a
second round of 50 million dollars I
could probably give you access to 4,000
of my angels and he said because now it
makes business sense and and I didn't
even get in to talk to him about the
creative this guy doesn't care about my
characters he doesn't care about the
story he cares about the model of it and
but the the creative decisions were the
things that created those opportunities
for those other products and other
things so it goes it works together so
you can never really separate it and so
it you know that just shows you and like
the other example that the guy that
going out after the $10,000 investment
getting in 231 thousand dollar
investment that's the other end of the
spectrum but the result is very similar
one thing doesn't make business sense
but when you can now create a project
that makes business sense now yet
everything makes much more sense and
what it does it hedges the investment it
makes the investment more secure because
all investors are risk-averse they they
don't want to just throw their money
away and so if you can make them more
comfortable with the fact that the the
investment is secure now they said okay
this is you know I'm part of this for
the long term there's here there's
opportunity here here here and here now
it just makes a lot more sense for them
and you know and then you incur it's
still difficult don't get me wrong it's
still difficult but you just increase
the chances for success and also
separate yourself the marketplace and so
you know Tim Kring the guy that created
Heroes he just got a 50 million dollar
investment into a transmedia company
that he started with another guy here in
town called Zach Kass and they they
created a whole transmedia company and
they went to an oilman in Texas and this
oil man said I've never invested in
entertainment ever in my whole life but
when they approached me with this
transmedia model it made business sense
and so and so he you know dumps 50
million dollars into their venture and
so what it what it does is is it gives
you access to to a different type of
investment and more investors when you
can really understand how how markets
work how we can get more audience how we
can get different types of audience how
you know how we can diversify income
excetera etc etc all this sounds very
uncreated right I mean yeah I can see
like screenwriters watching this video
probably cringing right now but what was
really interesting is is none of these
other opportunities of the tie ends or
the spin-offs or the other products that
you can that you can surround your
project with that those won't be
possible or at least possible in a good
way if you don't create the story to be
able to optimize it for that go back to
that Lukas example he made the creative
decision to have eight characters in a
scene rather than to that then fueled
hundreds of thousands of dollars worth
of revenue and an engagement opportunity
for the fan pace so so the story drives
the business let's take Close Encounters
of the Third Kind and and Star Wars
let's say they both came out around the
same time why did one have a longer
shelf life and the other one is just
this amazing nostalgic film that those
of us at that time remember fondly it's
fascinating to look at that case study
because yeah you have two films that had
similar budgets both had similar type of
filmmakers they were targeting a very
similar audience they're released at the
same time like everything is the same
one becomes a really good movie that
people love and actually is it pretty
well close to calendars in the Third
Kind another becomes a fifty billion
dollar brand and so what there's a
variable in there somewhere that created
that separation in the marketplace and
week weekend we can look at that and
probably guess pretty closely why that
happened there's a book that I read
recently called how Star Wars conquered
the universe where they asked Steven
Spielberg this exact same question
and because him and him and Lucas would
actually give each other producer points
on all of their movies and so so Lucas
had producer points on Close Encounters
Spielberg had producer points on Star
Wars
obviously the Spielberg got a better
part of that deal but and they said well
why you know why did it work out so well
for Lucas and you know pretty well for
you but it's not even in the same
ballpark
he said there's two reasons he said from
the beginning Lucas approached this
project not as just a single film he
always had a broader vision he
understood that there was story before
this there's gonna be story after this
maybe he didn't have all the things
planned out exactly and have it all
worked out
but his vision was very big from the
beginning and secondly he said he had a
world that people wanted to explore hey
the story world he said I never even
gave any a thought of my story world the
the setting of Close Encounters our
world that's just being invaded by
aliens but what he did he created a
world that people wanted to continue to
explore and and and if you can create a
world in an IP and illustrate that
people want to continue to explore then
all of a sudden that then makes the room
for the other things that you want to do
and so you know what's really
interesting about Lucas in the same book
is that he didn't grow up wanting to be
a filmmaker he wanted he grew up wanting
to be an architect and he worked at his
dad's toy store every summer as a kid
and so he approached filmmaking not from
the filmmaking standpoint he has
approached it from a architectural and
toy standpoint and and and he still went
in to make a good movie of course but he
then approached it the industry and the
creative and the writing of it in a
completely different way that then
fueled all these opportunities if you
look at from the original Star Wars
movie the the cantina scene where Luke
and obi-wan they go into the cantina and
there's all those crazy aliens around
and they this is where they find Han
Solo for the first time there was there
was a very specific choice of
uh I want these crazy aliens all around
that they could have had to cut back on
budget they could have had everybody
look human like Luke if they wanted to
but instead he really made sure that
every single character in that bar and
in that cantina looked had a very
distinctive look that they they seem
mysterious that they it was obvious that
all of them had some sort of backstory
involved and just that created one the
writing decision to the direct oral
decision if you watch the scene the way
they made sure they got shots of all of
them there were interesting ones in the
foreground in the background they took
time in the in the edit of the film to
cut cut cut and show a handful of them
then those creative opportunities both
in the writing the directing and the
editing then fuelled short stories and
video games and cartoons that dealt with
all of them they created web content for
all of them they created game content
for all of them and they created toys
for all of them so now all of a sudden
where most filmmakers and directors
would say my scene is about my
protagonist and my antagonist and this
the character our central characters
everything else is background Lucas
never considered anybody background he
looked at all these other characters as
potential stories potential stories
potential stories that just so happened
to be in the background of this scene
but I'm going to develop all of them as
if they could be the heroes of their own
story and then put them in the
background so so now the creative
mindset is different when he approaches
a story so how do we do that as
independent filmmakers on my hundred
thousand dollar feature well all of a
sudden the roommate of your protagonist
now that's just in the background on a
few different scenes now you should take
the time to think how do I make that guy
interesting or that girl interesting how
do I give them an interesting look or an
interesting backstory how do I make them
if how could I make them the
protagonists of their own story I'm
going to develop them as if they're they
could be and then I'll go back and put
them in the background now when I
approach my short film this really
interesting weird eclectic character is
now in there that
then spur a whole companion novel maybe
it's a EP of music maybe it's a soul
social media account for this crazy
characters tweeting back and forth that
leading up or after the film there's
lots of different things used in the
principles that you see from Lucas and
now applying that into your your
specific smaller project Houston with
your first book can make your story
really stinking big is this sort of an
entrepreneurial view of storytelling or
do you also cover craft and technique
both I I think that it you need to
approach storytelling from an
entrepreneurial mindset it's just so
that you can as a writer and a producer
and a creator you can you can have more
you can be empowered more rather than
I'm gonna write something and then I'm
gonna push it out and now I'm at the
mercy of the entertainment gods to do
whatever they want with my stuff if you
approach it from an entrepreneurial
mindset you can now have more
opportunity to take control of of your
work but here's here's the trick is that
if you don't approach everything you do
with craft and technique then your
products won't be good and so in an
transmedia business model we have a
diversified product line if not just the
film but a film Plus this Plus this Plus
this that all work together for one
amazing experience if you if if you
don't perfect your craft and technique
for all of them then all of a sudden
nothing's gonna work and it doesn't
matter how good your business model is
if your stories aren't good and people
don't care about them and people don't
engage with your characters and if your
products aren't good your business isn't
good and so there's it's an interesting
balance of understanding the
entrepreneur model and then being able
to harness the craft and technique for
the individual products within that
model that's the sweet spot of how to
have a how to make the whole thing work
because a lot of people say well you
know what do you think every movie needs
transmedia do you think every it can't
you just leave room for a film that that
doesn't need it because you know does
this hit that Hemingway really needed to
franchise old man in the sea
you know this moonlight really need you
know transmedia extensions and and
because typically any offshoot that you
have of an original work isn't as good
as the original and you know if you have
sort of the companion this and the
spin-off this and the tie and this
sometimes they're just not as good and
they actually diminish they can diminish
the original work because you surrounded
it with this crap and and and I can't
argue that necessarily that that doesn't
happen because it does this is why the
creators need to approach the the the
transmedia model and every touch point
of that model with that the the craft
and the technique and to make sure that
everything is great because if you tell
me that not not everything needs you
know Manchester by the sea like does
that really need you know a first-person
shooter that goes along with it well
maybe not a first-person shooter but but
maybe there is a book of poetry that
goes along with it maybe there's a novel
that goes along with it maybe there's a
a companion album that's the different
than the soundtrack and an album that
tells a story from another character's
perspective that adds to the story in a
really interesting way maybe the things
that fit the brand maybe it could use
that because what you tell what you're
telling me when you say not everything
needs transmedia this is what you're
really telling me you're telling me that
audience doesn't need more of your story
and you're also telling me that your
investors don't need any more money and
neither one of those things should be
true the highest the highest compliment
up for an artist for a filmmaker is for
an audience to say I love what you did
and I want more of it it's the highest
compliment you could ever receive not
just it was great it was great and I
want more it's the highest compliment
you can get and so for you as a
filmmaker you have to try to figure out
how do I give them more how do I give
them more how do I continue to cultivate
and engage my fan base but it's too
expensive to be able to do movies all
the time so now we have to look at the
rest of our
toolkit I mean imagine going to a
imagine going to a restaurant and you
have the most amazing entree you've ever
had in your life like life-changing meal
and you call the waiter over and you say
I love this I'm still hungry it was the
greatest meal I've ever had I want to
order something else off the menu and
they say absolutely not you say well
that's kind of weird because I'm still
hungry I want more can i order maybe a
dessert nope
can i order an appetizer absolutely not
well why because I have money in my
pocket that I want to give you because I
love the first meal so much well the
chef feels the chef feels that if he
gives you anything else it could
diminish the experience of the first so
the chef thinks you shouldn't you need
to be happy with this one thing right
now it doesn't make sense for it in a
consumer arena to have that conversation
but if we now port that back over into
entertainment that's the conversation
we're having you're telling me that this
audience member that says I love the
first thing I want more than that you're
telling me you know what me the chef the
filmmaker I don't feel like it you
should have anything else I think
because it could diminish the experience
the first thing you just need to be
happy that's not a way to build to build
a brand it's not a way to build a
business it's not a way to build an
audience base I would never go back to
that restaurant but here's how if if
that if I somehow convinced them to
bring me another dish and then there was
a there was a hair in it or a fingernail
in it or something awful then maybe it
would diminish the experience the first
and that's what we've all experienced in
multimedia franchises you know even even
some transmedia franchises where the
where the creators create the first
thing and then for all the other stuff
they leave it to other people they
license it out through a license model
they just like and they and all those
other things aren't approached with the
same passion technique and care that the
original was and then it does diminish
the value of the first so to be able to
take care of this to take it
this model now the creator needs to have
this mindset from the beginning so that
they can now approach those other things
with the same technique and the same
craft and and now when they get the
second dish and they get the third dish
and the fourth dish they're just as as
good if not better than the original and
and then the the experience is actually
enhanced rather than diminished so for
example Quentin Tarantino when Quentin
Tarantino did Django Unchained there was
a there was a multimedia comic book that
was produced that was Django the comic
book it was the same story in both
places and and it wasn't very good and
people were complaining about it and it
was just it was just barely very poorly
put together well later Quentin
Tarantino released the official sequel
to Django Unchained so the official
sequel to Django Unchained is in a movie
it's actually a comic book that was the
story was created by Quentin Tarantino
himself and it's called Django / Zorro
so it's a Zorro
Django crossover that's the official
sequel to the movie Django Unchained
but the story one its new story so it
continues the story of Django but the
story was created and cultivated and
designed by Quentin Tarantino and then
he just had comic-book people put it put
it together because he doesn't know
comic books but he worked with the team
and made sure that the craft the passion
and the technique that he put into the
original film was then put into this
trans mediated extension and then all of
a sudden that where the fans hated the
first comic book they loved the second
comic book because not only was it new
story but it was new story that was
crafted by the creator in the same way
he crafted the original so that's a very
long way to answer the question but it
but it's an intersection of both it's an
entrepreneurial mindset for the business
model and then and then how you execute
within that business model is with craft
and technique at every single touch
point to work together that I think is
the sweet spot
when you talk about the entrepreneurial
aspects of building a story or a frame
Chai's what are some of the counter
points that students or people that have
read your book say yeah and also to what
are the age groups of the people that
are countering your stance yeah that the
the people that sort of push back
against it yeah yeah so uh so the big
the the biggest pushback is is what what
I was just talking about is the biggest
pushback as always it's going to
diminish it's going to diminish the the
beginning you know it's going to
diminish the first thing it's going to
diminish the first experience that they
have and but for me it's look that that
looks at the the whole situation from a
I don't say selfish point of view but it
it's looking at it just from a
filmmakers perspective and not from an
audience perspective there's a there's a
school of thought a philosophy out there
called phenomenology and phenomenology
states that the highest achievement of
the artist isn't the creation of the art
itself it's actually the experience that
the audience has with the art is that's
the highest achievement that you can get
and so a lot of a painter that paints a
painting once these finished with the
painting that's that's not the highest
achievement they that he has it's only
until someone has an experience with the
painting that you actually have ever
achieved something so if you create a
painting that no one ever sees if you're
out of book that no one ever reads or
makes them make a movie that no one ever
watches
according to phenomenology you actually
haven't created anything that's just the
first step and to be a phenomenal
filmmaker or a phenomenal creator you
have to create things that people have
these dynamic experiences with which
means you have to be thinking of the
audience and the audience's experience
with your brand and your project from
the beginning and that's a very
different mindset that most filmmakers
have they think of what's the story I
want to tell and though in the way I
want to tell it and it's all about me
and my vision and it's very insular and
the way they approach the project
because it's it's the
their craft and their art but to be a
phenomenal filmmaker you have to say
what's the story I want to tell and how
do I want to tell it but you always have
in the back of your mind or maybe in the
front of your mind how ultimately is the
audience going to be experiencing it and
what is the audience want and and and
it's the balance of those two that can
move you out of just being a filmmaker
to a phenomenal filmmaker and so what
the audience wants right now is they
want more story they want more of this
amazing world that you created more of
these amazing characters that you've
created and and we have to now figure
out how to deliver more and more and
more story to them but in a way that
doesn't diminish the original work in it
and and I'm not saying this is easy the
the this this causes you to now not just
think of a two-hour story you know when
you're making a movie you're thinking of
120 pages and that's it and I'm done now
that's just step one now I got to think
almost like in a television mindset of
where I'm not just creating the pilot
episode I'm creating the pilot episode
the rest of the first season and seven
seasons from here on out and so now
you're thinking of 100 stories rather
than one and so now you have to have
that sort of facility to say how do I
tell a hundred stories that spin off of
my movie because this is what my
audience wants and so that that that's
the trick and that's the big pushback
another pushback is I don't know how to
do the other stuff I don't know how to
make comic books I don't know how to
make music I don't know how to make any
of this stuff well the the good the good
thing is that there are people who do in
every industry every creative industry
out here there are people that are
looking for collaborations and
partnerships and because they're trying
to figure out how to break in as well so
you can find yeah you throw a rock at
any direction in Hollywood you're going
to hit a screenwriter you throw another
rock in another direction you're going
to hear somebody trying to break into
the music industry some of us trying to
break into the to the as a playwright
into the stage industry you're gonna
somebody's trying to break into
animation and design
and all of a sudden if I'm trying to
break in in film and you're trying to
break in and music then if I go to you
and say listen here's an opportunity to
collaborate and I have this movie I'm
trying to get made if if we can figure
out how to how to partner on a musical
extension that's going to extend the
story and it really dynamic way and
maybe we could shoot music videos that
sort of coincide and then he is an
animation guy and so maybe he can create
animated music videos for the music that
you then create and then all this works
around the movie that I'm going to
create now we can create this really
interesting transmedia project and all
and all benefit from the partnership
because we're leveraging each other
you know a fire ants are really
interesting is where I was watching this
nature video where fire ants in the
Amazon when it floods fire ants they
they they clip their jaws together and
they hold on to each other and they
create these massive like it looks like
a raft that floats on top of the water
individually the fire ants will drowned
in the flood but as soon as they see the
water company good coming they latch
their jaws on create a raft and they all
float on top and that in it in an
industry as competitive as Hollywood
where we it's not just filmmakers as
filmmakers and authors and musicians and
everybody in between when when the water
is rushing all the time the way for us
to see to succeed especially when we're
trying to break in isn't just to
insulate ourselves individually it I
feel like it's it's cross-platform
multidisciplinary teams of people let's
lock our jaws together and figure out
how we can float together on top of the
water rather than just drowned
individually so I think this
collaboration is out there to be made
that can help that can help that problem
and to we're good we're all good at lots
of things in today's world it's very
difficult to find somebody who only does
one thing especially younger people
right anybody this especially under 30
they've grown up in a world where that
you know everybody can take pictures
because the phones you know
phone everybody is a hobby photographer
at this point you know you're an
Instagram photographer everybody knows
how to make a movie and edit it kind of
everybody knows how to you know using
GarageBand or something on a Mac they
know how to create a song and and and
produce a song to some extent we all
know how to maybe probably we could
probably all figure out how to launch a
website in some way using online web
materials and so all of a sudden if you
really think about it we all have
facilities in five or six different ways
that we could probably figure out how to
create some of this stuff ourselves if
we had to and so we can create a website
companion to our movie that extends the
story in a valuable way and at the same
time have an Instagram account for uh
from the perspective of one of the
characters in the movie that disappears
in act one and doesn't reappear in act
two all of a sudden or maybe they
reappear in act 3 then where are they
all through act two is now told on the
Instagram account and so that that now
the Instagram account is working with
the movie that's also working with the
website and you can do all that your
stuff yourself because we're all pretty
good at everything right and so those
are the two biggest the two biggest push
backs is is I don't want to diminish the
original work and I don't know how to do
everything and and I don't have the
money to do it
that's the third biggest thing is I
don't have the money to do it well it's
it's that with these boxes that are in
our pockets you that that shoot 4k
resolution that that we all have
GarageBand on our phones and our on our
laptops like we could we all have access
to social media that's completely for
free we should be able to shoot create
and extend stories completely for free
maybe we're not making big motion
pictures maybe we're not making platform
video games but there should be a way
for everybody on a zero budget to be
able to continue to engage their
audience or even establish an audience
in a dynamic way completely for free I
knew these guys that created a podcast
and they wanted to they wanted to launch
an independent movie and that was sort
of this it was about this crazy wacky
kind of haunted town and it was this
really weird thing this got across that
they shopped it around they couldn't get
it they couldn't get any traction on it
so they went and created a podcast and
the podcast is is from the perspective
of the of the radio DJ in that town and
he just and he talks about like the
crazy things that happen in the town the
different characters they interview some
of the characters on there and it's just
this weekly podcast that gives sort of
the weekly news of the crazy town the
podcast has blown up the world they have
hundreds of thousands of subscribers to
this podcast what they've done now is
they've established pre awareness for
their project and now they take that a
couple hundred thousand loyal audience
that they have for the podcast and have
leveraged that into a film deal because
there's a they've proved the marketplace
is ready for this project right and so
to create a Fahd cast it cost zero money
completely zero dollars right and so and
so they just recognized the tool and I'm
not talking about a podcast that where
you're talking about your movie right
right it's like it's it there's a
difference between in world and outer
world
when we're talking what I'm talking
about transmedia is in world extensions
so works Tim then we're inside the world
and we're extending the story in various
ways I'm not talking about behind the
scenes cast and crew interviews and
think those are valuable and valuable in
different ways typically they're
valuable after something's been released
but when really Trent we're talking
about transmedia and super story and
these things like this but I'm not
getting inside the world and extending
in valuable ways and so and there's so
many tools at our disposal that we don't
even know that are there that that could
we can use to be able to extend and and
I was watching the the pilot episode of
better call Saul there was a character
who wanted Saul Goodman to be his lawyer
and said Saul Goodman didn't want to be
his lawyer because this guy was sort of
this mean criminal kind of a guy so this
guy writes his phone number on a
matchbook and throws it on the on the
desk and say call me
and for me I mean the transmedia guy I
pause the TV and I call the number
because of course I would and I called
the number and I get the characters
voicemail
Wow right and so doing little things
like that you can do almost for free
very inexpensive very easily yourself
right now when you say I'm going to
create my want to write my book and or
I'm gonna release my movie I'm gonna now
implant these things into the scene
where people can just use their cell
phones call the different numbers get
the different number that the characters
voicemails be able to leave them
voicemails be able to listen to their
voice mails and be able to set you know
set up these fake phone numbers you can
do you do one phone number for a year
for like 14 bucks that just goes to
voicemail very inexpensive but at the
same time very valuable to the fanbase
and it just kind of makes it feel
different like wow this is cool I'm like
doing this really interesting thing so
so there's lots of tools that we can use
that we just don't know are there that
are very expensive you don't need you
don't need the Star Wars budget to be
able to use the principles of Star Wars
right you don't you don't need this
stuff we just need that we just need the
principles to understand the rubric and
now we're used to those low cost those
low cost tools to attack the marketplace
in a very different way houston with
your current book make your story really
stinkin big you have a chapter entitled
build your characters a house to live in
yes can we talk about a little bit that
entails yeah absolutely
so what what's interesting now is from a
transmedia perspective from a super
story perspective the The Producers
Guild of America has ratified a
transmedia producer credit and they they
ratified that a few years ago and they
say you need three story lines and at
least three mediums that all operate in
one narrative universe and that one
narrative universe is what I call a
story world and so now to be able to
approach a transmedia project or any
sort of project we we now need to not
just think about the individual story
that we want to tell we need to think
about the place where the story takes
place the world in
which the story lives and that's what I
call a story world and that's that one
narrative universe that the PGA talks
about and so there's a difference
between story world and story the the
story of Dorothy and the tornado and
Landon and Oz and and going on the
adventure of the the yellow brick road
is a story but the story world is oz
itself that is much bigger than then
then Dorothy Dorothy's just a single
story that takes place in a much bigger
world Luke Skywalker is just as his his
epic journey to destroy the Death Star
and you know the the story of the
dysfunctional Skywalker's the Skywalker
family is just a single story in a much
bigger world the story of the matrix is
neo and Morpheus and and their adventure
trying to deconstruct and tear down the
matrix itself but the story world of the
matrix is a futuristic earth that's been
taken over by machines and they use
people's batteries and put them in a
weird VR environment as they use them as
batteries that's the world of the matrix
which is much bigger than just neo and
Morpheus a story that's just one story
that you can tell and so now we're I
look at at not just what the individual
story is but what's the story world that
we need to build around that story
because what happens is if you if you
build your story world ride one it'll be
more attractive to an audience remember
one of the two reasons that Spielberg
told said that that Star Wars was so
much more valuable than Close Encounters
is because he said that that Lucas built
a world where people wanted to explore
and so the story world is a key
component in in multi-platform success
because that holds the rest of your
story potential so one it engaged is
more engaging for the initial story that
you want to tell but also it creates
more potential for more stories moving
forward so it if we put it into a
consumer like a consumer model and if
your individual stories if you look at
them as commodities and so my individual
story is an orange and I need I need to
sell my orange in order to get money and
this is my business and if if I just
have if I'm holding oranges I could
probably just only only hold the couple
in
dividual oranges and to take them out to
the side of road to sell but if I want
to sell more oranges I need a box and if
I have a big box now I can have 30 40 50
60 oranges depending on how big my box
is then I can now take to the to the
side of the road to sell my oranges and
my orange stand so the box
having the box to hold my oranges
increases my revenue potential for my
venture the story world is the box that
holds your individual stories and so
some of some story rolls are very big
like Star Wars like Star Trek like Game
of Thrones and Westeros the gigantic
story worlds other story worlds are much
smaller but at the same time they can
still hold multiple oranges which
increases revenue potential so these are
the things that attract investors and
attract buyers but we have to look at
the building of a story world as a
separate discipline of telling a story
and it's something that that most people
don't look at as a separate some of the
separate discipline or a separate style
of creation because just because you're
a good storyteller doesn't mean you're a
good world builder just because you're a
good world builder doesn't mean you're a
good storyteller
you need both and in order to to succeed
on sort of these these big levels but
but but so in my original book make your
story really stinking big I outline some
strategies of world-building
of it's not building a world and telling
a bad story that won't work because if
you build a great world and tell a bad
story your products not going to be any
good you know I'm a fan of a big world's
big you know I grew up Star Wars
Lord of the Rings type of stuff so I I
like these big worlds but you look at
something like the Wachowskis when they
did Jupiter ascending and that was a
tremendous world that they built but the
movie was very was was was not as good
as the world which ultimately made the
project just not sustainable and so you
can build a great world but if you have
a bad product that you put out bad movie
bad book bad TV show it's just not going
to work if you tell a great story
with a bad world you could win an Oscar
but you're not gonna be able to extend
the life of the project and be able to
do all the other things that you want to
do because your your multi-platform
potential and your revenue potential and
your stored potential all reside in the
story world itself so so now we need
both we know these two things that we
need to be able to tell what I think is
a 21st century story is we need a great
story world and great stories within
those worlds that's what's great about
the Hunger Games the world the Hunger
Games is really interesting and cool and
but at the same time Katniss's story
within that really cool world is
emotional and engaging and something
that people can all get behind Harry's
story and Harry Potter is interesting
and emotional and we want to follow that
but the world behind Harry is just a
school in a rule of thumb that I use is
if you can take out your main character
and what's left is really cool and
interesting you probably have a good
story world so like we can take Katniss
out of The Hunger Games and Panem which
is the story world is still really
interesting and cool even without
Katniss it's really cool if you take
Batman out of got out of Gotham we're at
Batman - Batman you look you have Gotham
Gotham is such an interesting story
world they have a TV show Gotham that
that doesn't have Batman in it it's it
can sustain on its own you take Luke
Skywalker out of Star Wars arguably
you've made it better a lot of people
think he's the most annoying guy in
there
so there's other characters and other
interesting things that you can follow
same with Game of Thrones same with all
these things even something like
Deadwood on HBO Westworld the leftovers
I love these all have like dynamic story
worlds that aren't big Star Wars worlds
but they're really interesting
well-crafted stories that if you take
out I'm a big fan of the leftovers you
take out Nora
and you know in Kevin you take out the
main characters the rest of the world is
interesting same with West world the
same with everything but if you take
rocky out of Rocky right then you just
have Philly you know and I like 1970s
Philadelphia we
you can see the difference right and so
and so now what happens is that whole
brand around Rocky is only bit is built
on severe still owns aging shoulders and
you can't get away from him and I know
they're trying to pass the torch to
Creed and that was good but but you can
see where they've been limited because
they didn't build a great story world
but they want an Oscar right and so my
thing is let's win an Oscar and build a
great story world around it so we can
extend and expand as much as we want and
so in that original book make your story
really stinking big I outlined some
strategy in my new book you're gonna
need a bigger story then I even go into
more strategy about it because what
we've seen in the past couple years is
is there's been a there's been a premium
put on how to create great story worlds
from independent creators that when they
go shop stuff when they go shop a spec
script the scripts that have great story
worlds or have been getting
disproportionately good deals that as
opposed to the the scripts that are good
that she'll have good story worlds so if
you look at the spec deal
the average spec deals say is $200,000
$250,000 the specs that have great story
worlds have been getting picked up two
million dollars three million dollars
two and a half million dollars because
the studios that look at those they'll
say that has one good story in it but
this other thing has one good story plus
forty other stories that I could
potentially tell across platform so I
see video games I see TV I see multiple
features that see cartoons
I see comic books so from a studio's
perspective all of a sudden spending two
million dollars from 40 stories rather
than two hundred thousand dollars on one
story is it better as a better buy it's
like going to Costco and buying in bulk
and so if they think if they if I can
buy the big IP that has lots of story
potential now this is a wise long-term
investment for us and so I just I just
took two projects to China and over the
past you know a couple months
and win over without a script and sat
with oscar-winning producers who said we
don't really look at things without
without a script and I say well let's
let's talk about the world that I built
let's talk about the world where all
these stories are going to take place
and all of a sudden I get an attachment
from a producer again attachment from
the biggest director in China I get an
attachment from you know another from a
person that used to run a studio over
there that's coming on as a producer
then all of a sudden I'm attaching all
these people and I don't even have a
script I just have this really
interesting world that I've built where
they see all the different story
potential and all of a sudden now
financers come find it and and then
writers look at it and say I would love
to write in that sandbox I want to play
in that sandbox and so it's a really
interesting time now in the market place
where the story world has has has taken
its own separate spot in the marketplace
it hasn't has an overtaken story in
priority because again if you don't have
a great story your products not gonna
work
but the story world as being a separate
asset as being separately built and and
have its own its own style of creation
its own rubric of creation that has
really been coming into prominence with
with sci-fi project fantasy project but
at the same time very very like real
world based projects that that you know
you see an HBO that you that we you know
dramas if you have a good story world
then it has good good story potential
which means has get a revenue potential
and shelf life for all the different
players within the within the project so
in my new book I go into greater detail
because of this sort of this change in
the marketplace of the store world being
a separate asset even going to you know
probably 50% more styles of creation and
things that you should think about
little tricks of the trade that really
help you whether you're building Star
Wars or you're building your one hour
domestic drama these are the things that
can help you help the revenue potential
of the world itself so then when you set
the table with the world you can jump in
and tell this amazing heartfelt
emotional story then all of a sudden
you're hitting on both fronts and your
project actually has now has more
potential both financially and
creatively well that was my question
actually you're reading my mind because
I was thinking with real world I don't I
wasn't seeing how transmedia would work
if you take let's say the 80s films of
John Hughes sure fantastic movies
what worlds aside from like suburbia in
nineteen late 1980s could really be
there or the high school dramas of you
know Molly Ringwald or something yeah
you know because it seems like yeah with
with science fiction or some of these
comic book films there's endless
possibilities for these worlds yeah but
is their endless pasar they're endless
possibilities for a drama or even take
Silicon Valley great show or maybe maybe
they're more so but if you look at some
of the films of you know that are more
drama based or you have an romantic
comedy sure are their chances for a
world oh I think absolutely because I'm
in Silicon Valley is the the is a great
example because outside of the specific
characters in the Silicon Valley show
Silicon Valley itself the world of
Silicon Valley it's very interesting and
fascinating the way that whole thing
runs and the people who reside there you
can see more than one story than just
you know handful of characters right and
so so now you're just it's taken the
Google Earth view of of a story and
saying what I have right here is that is
that interesting so you could have
something like like rocky for example
you know right I say right you take
rocky out of Philadelphia well if if I
wanted to try to retrofit transmedia
around rocky I'm gonna have to try to
figure out the story world of Rocky and
so now I'm gonna look at okay
Philadelphia and then I'll say okay well
what is it about Philadelphia that
what's the most unique thing about Rocky
I think the most unique thing about
Rocky is the fact that he was he was an
untrained boxer he's not even just an
untrained boxer he's he is that he
started out as a leg breaker for the
who then becomes a boxer who then takes
on the champ so he's a guy that has been
he's a guy that is not trained for the
industry that he wants to go into and
against all odds is able to overcome all
that and succeed at the highest level so
then I would say okay what is it about
maybe there's other people that live in
this other this part of Philadelphia who
do the same thing remember there was a
movie invincible Mark Wahlberg was a he
was a bartender who tries out for the
Philadelphia Eagles and makes the
Philadelphia Eagles based on a true
story that I think is a similar thematic
and a similar high concept is rocky
somebody who's not trained to go into
the industry that they want to go into
and against all odds overcome that
obstacle and succeed at the highest
level and so maybe I start to look at
the different parts of Philadelphia and
say you know there's Fishtown in
Philadelphia there's a part of
Philadelphia that that rocky some is a
part of called the devil's pockets it's
a little like suburb not a suburb but
like a like a little borough almost of
Philadelphia so then I can say okay what
is it about the people who live in the
devil's pocket part of Philadelphia and
and there's something about the grit and
determination of just how you the people
who live there in the day to day
struggle and the lives that they live
and and what they do to survive every
single day that gives them the grit and
determination to say you know what I can
do anything that I want to do I can be a
boxer if I want I don't care if I'm
trained or not because I grew up in the
devil's pocket I know I can do all these
amazing things I can be I can play for
the Eagles maybe you can tell a story
about the about a you know somebody
wants to become a ballerina that is you
know former drug dealer out of a gang
that wants to become a professional
ballerina Flashdance exactly anything
like that the we're now now this this
world the devils pocket this little part
of Philadelphia is creating people with
the guts and the maxime the grit that
where they can go out and against all
odds achieve everything they want to do
now maybe rocky balboa has the feature
films but then maybe
there's a book series about the
ballerina that you want to tell maybe
there's a whole musical extension that
you want to tell about somebody who
wants to who wants to pursue music
maybe there's a video game about
somebody else that wants to do something
and now we've identified this a really
interesting world and then we can tie
all those stories together because if
you look at something like well it's
just on NBC Chicago Fire Chicago med
Chicago PD
Chicago everything though all the
Chicago says on NBC they're all set in
one story world and then they cross over
and so they're all set in Chicago and
they all cross over in some really
interesting ways that's not transmedia
cuz it's all TV you don't shift your
mediums but the story world of Chicago
supports multiple stories of multiple
people and and then allows you to cross
over in some interesting ways if you
look at Chicago even you have you have
all the great stories that have been
told in Chicago from the 8th in and out
which was the old baseball movie with
Charlie Sheen that was about the old
Chicago Black Sox that threw the World
Series 1918 baseball movie set in
Chicago you have Glengarry Glen Ross is
a business movie set in Chicago you have
less Natural Born Killers started in
Chicago there's a horror movie like a
serial killer movie in Chicago you have
Meet the Fockers one of those was in
Chicago you have divergent and insurgent
which is post-apocalyptic Chicago you
have the it was the Will Smith movie I
Robot I Robot set and futuristic Chicago
so what's interesting is all those
stories exist within the same story
world just in different parts of the
timeline right so from 1918 all the way
to post-apocalyptic dystopian Chicago
and so those all exist in the same story
world which now now if you're thinking
as a broader vision of a project you say
what is my story world what is my you
know if my story world is is is
Philadelphia or Chicago or whatever now
how do I explore the people that live in
that world
but now also how do I shift back and
forth Lin timeline to
other stories that I can figure out how
to then tie in because then all of a
sudden if in if in iRobot the main
character finds a there's something that
they find in that world that then gives
them a clue as to who actually through
the World Series back in 1918 now you
tie this story that's a sci-fi story
back to the old baseball story that's
over here on the timeline and you're
connecting everything in an interesting
way and it becomes a game for your fan
base so it's not always about the big
Star Wars you know thing it's about how
do I identify a part of our world that's
interesting and cool that and sometimes
you have to engineer that right and so I
can engineer like that the neighborhood
where rocky grew up in as this
neighborhood that churns out other
people like rocky that have similar
stories maybe in some in different
industries and to be able to explore it
across platform now that's just as much
as a story world as Harry Potter maybe
it's a smaller box to carry the orange
and maybe it's as sort of a different
genre but it's the same principles that
build it so in your first book and make
your story really stinking big you have
chapter 10 and some sage advice yes
sort of the ending chapter I guess yes
what some sage advice that you can share
from the book so the the biggest thing I
would tell people that are either trying
to break in or that already are in and
they're trying to figure out how to stay
afloat is to think outside the paradigm
outside of the the path that we're all
given the same door that everybody's
supposed to go through the same the same
way that we're supposed to do things
start thinking outside those boxes
because when you can think outside those
boxes there's more opportunities than
you then you realize to actually
differentiate yourself in the
marketplace and continue to do the thing
that you love the most which is tell
stories and which is then to create
things that people can can can
participate in and be affected by and so
it's it for me it's a the mindset of
having a mindset of disruption having a
mindset of innovation having a mindset
of an entrepreneur who builds a consumer
brand rather than how a producer builds
an entertainment brand if you if if
anybody builds an entertainment brand
the way an entrepreneur builds a
consumer brand you build it differently
because there's different different
principles at play but but for some
reason people live in this little
Hollywood bubble and they think free
market economics doesn't does it impact
anything we're just all about story in
our in our as long as I just write good
scripts that I'm good and sadly for you
know 95% of writers out here even
working writers that the just writing a
a great just being great at your
individual craft isn't enough and you
know unless you're one of like the top
a-list you know number one person in the
town or the top 10 riders in the town
everybody's trying to figure out how do
I stop going from paycheck to paycheck
how do I stop because even if you're
even if you're like a list you're still
going to paycheck to paycheck there's
all those periods of uncertainty there's
always periods where where the the new
up-and-comers are in there and things
start to wind down a little bit you got
to get there and hustle there may be big
paychecks to big paychecks but there's
the stress and the pressure that is just
around this industry that if you don't
start thinking outside of the paradigm
you it's just it'll it'll wear you down
after a while and and so so the biggest
advice I could get
it's just get out there and look at all
the tools that you have at your disposal
and figure out how to use all of them in
the best way how to how to look at
models that have been there for a
hundred years and say say how do I
incremental e-diff deviate from them how
can i how can i operate within it but
the same time put pressure on it from
the outside to start to change it how
can i establish myself and my brand as a
writer and a filmmaker as a different
and all these other 8 million people
that are trying to do the exact same
thing as me how do I do all those things
and it so that it's not always how do I
just write the better script because
it's very difficult to write the better
script so so now I if if if you put
yourself in a disruption mindset and an
innovation mindset I'm thinking outside
the box I'm kicking the box down the
road and and looking at it from a
completely different mindset now there's
opportunities that they'll seed that
they didn't see before because they were
too myopic right they'll see that maybe
you know maybe if I if I create a
multi-platform transmedia super story
that has a film and a book series and a
TV show and a video game component and a
mobile game component then if I build
that I can shop it as a movie but at the
same time I can also shop it as TV but
at the same time I can also shop it as a
video game but at the same time I can
also shop it as a book series I worked
with it with a filmmaker who who was
trying to shop a TV pilot for years and
and I said ok well let's let's build
some of this stuff out and she built a
book series into her plan she as she was
shopping a TV pilot she was able to take
this book series and may get a get a
publishing deal out of it where she was
never able to get the TV deal but she
ended up selling it as to a publisher
got a publishing deal is now working off
there at with books and is using the
audience she's building from the books
now the TV public the TV networks are
coming to her to to say can we put your
books on TV and so and so what that did
is it gave her not just one outlet that
she just kept going after cuz she's like
I'm a TV writer all I can do is TV this
think a little bit bigger this thing
differently and think about how to
approach the marketplace differently
what the the networks and the studios
and all the buyers what they what they
really buy is audience what they buy is
pre awareness and so that they don't
studios and networks don't read
things because they love them the people
didn't greenlight the studio's didn't
green like Baywatch because they love
Baywatch
they green-lighted they greenlit
Baywatch because there's there's a pre
awareness of Baywatch that makes the
investment less risky and so if you
understand the principle of what they
love is pre awareness then all your job
is as a creator is to how do I create
pre awareness if I can create pre
awareness for my TV show create pre
awareness for my movie I've solved the
problem because if they love pre
awareness I'm gonna give them pre
awareness but how do I do pre wareness
for a movie if I'm a filmmaker I can't
do pre awareness for a movie by making
another movie because then it's a
catch-22 well the way you do pre and
weariness for a movie is now do
something other than a movie let's go
out and do something that we know we can
do it easy in the marketplace that can
quickly build a bill an audience maybe
you publish your own book maybe do music
these social media etc etc etc and then
you build that pre awareness for it then
the studios and the networks they now
will listen to you have a different
conversation because you broaden your
thinking and you've established your pre
awareness not only that but you've
generated revenue made your investors
happy etc etc etc so you only get to
that point if you think outside the box
you have to think from a not from a
story perspective but an IP perspective
think from an IP perspective then again
execute in a story level but you always
have to think from an IP perspective so
that you can take advantage of different
opportunities but it seems like creating
a product it's easier to be a disruptor
it's easier you know you look at Apple
they they were the underdog for a while
were they targeted to people that were
the misfits you know their whole
campaign which was really cool and then
of course that type of person wanted to
buy those machines and look at Tesla
they you know it was it was a it was a
car that was not a Prius it was
something that was sexy and it spoke
volumes about who you were but in terms
of writing a script or or or getting a
series out there it seems like they
would be very difficult to differentiate
yourself yeah I mean it's
it's very difficult to differentiate
yourself that's that's why I say let's
let's its if it's different it's
difficult to differentiate yourself
within the television industry or you
know that from you know from all the
other series or from the all the other
features that are being created the one
way to differentiate yourself is to is
to differentiate and diversify your plan
and and and differentiate and diversify
your intellectual property to where now
it's not just a your IP and your project
isn't just a feature film there's all
these other components there when you do
that you differentiate yourself as a
creator okay right and so and you you
can look at somebody like JJ Abrams like
George Lucas their brand isn't the same
brand as any other filmmakers the people
look look at them almost in a different
category right and so that helps
differentiate you from the beginning
secondly if you get good at it what it
does is also allows you to do it for
other people so now you can go to
somebody who's making a movie and say
hey you ever thought about doing it like
this and if you've already done it a
couple times they'll come to you is say
hey can you help me do this to my
project one which is great for you
because you get paid for it and and and
secondly that continues just to build
your brand is this this disrupter type
of a person another thing that you could
that that I always talk about and try to
encourage people in is to figure out the
the passion and the purpose behind the
brand like what like how do you make
your brand important how do you make
your brand sort of connected to the like
the emotional foundation of people and
what people care about and it's the
thing called corporate social
responsibility if you can tap into how
how your entertainment brand isn't just
cool but how it's important on some
level then you actually you could
actually connect with the audience in a
different way not just in a cool way but
at an emotional way and so a lot of
times now what's been in vogue of how to
get series and features produced and
picked up is that before you go to the
networks or the studios or to whoever
that you want to shop these things too
is to figure out the thematic premise
behind your project I call it a soapbox
and as the what are you trying to say
about your project and with your project
you take the time to go build an
Advisory Council of organizations that
will endure not fun but and just come
alongside it and endorse you and so if
you you know if you have you know
something like get the movie get out
that is very much in one it's a great
movie but it's infused with this
race-conscious soap box that talked
together that really is seated with the
with the evils of racism and how you
know we you know it's very apparent but
if you have a project like that take the
time to go to you know
the n-double-a-cp to black lives matter
to some of these other organizations say
I just want you to endorse me and and
and and because the reason that I want
to create this project is I want to
enhance the lives of certain people in
this certain way if you have a project
that is like the leftovers that is all
about grief and how you manage grief and
how you manage loss and then all of a
sudden take the time to go find
organizations that are focused on how to
help people manage grief how to help
people manage loss
these are different there's authors that
write books about these things how do
you make those collaborations the
connections from the beginning then when
you go have those conversations with
networks and studios or investors you
can you can they can see the
organizations that are coming along side
of you and endorsing your project
because of what you're trying to say
with it that then also distinguishes you
in the marketplace as well because you
you now have you now you're now moored
to to organizations and entities that
that that have been well established in
in in society not only that if the
organization's endorse you then they're
donor basis and the people that they
that they connect with will also support
it which then proves that there's a
market for
Jack so so it's very this interesting
you know outline all this in the in my
new book where where it's figuring out
that emotional base that that emotional
foundation that can align yourself with
nonprofit entities other organizations
that then help differentiate yourself
then if you're if you're if you then
diversify the product line in a trans
mediated super story way now you're
hitting on both levels and you really
have something different so not only is
your project differentiated but you as a
creator have been differentiated
yourself and you have a different brand
yourself which is great but you only get
to that point is if you elevate your
elevate your thinking above I'm just a
filmmaker I'm just an author I'm just a
director that's all I am I all I do is
direct movies I'm a I'm a movie director
and that's it if you never think outside
of that box you'll never do anything
else you'll never take advantage of the
the hundreds of opportunities that
surround you every single day you know
you we have to be able to build that
build the car differently in it an
18-wheeler when it's going down the road
and it blows a tire keeps on going right
but if your filmmaker and you and and
you're riding down the road on a
unicycle and you blow that tire you fall
flat on your face all right so we have
to figure out the the machine that we're
riding needs to be built differently so
that we can we can we can help
differentiate ourselves and keep going
and float on top of the water right and
so mixing all my metaphors at this point
but but but you could what I'm trying to
say is that it's the mindset it's a
vision that if you don't have you're not
going to be able to take advantage of it
but if you do have there's so much stuff
that you can do it's incredible once
people it's like it's like seeing the
matrix right you don't now see oh I can
do that and I can do that and I can do
that and I can do that and I can
collaborate with this person that can
generate over no revenue over here and
now I can do this and generate pre
awareness within loops be background to
have better conversations with the
network studios and investors that I
wanted to have conversations with from
the beginning all the while building
this really dynamic robust audience base
that will then follow you for your
entire career as long as you keep
feeding them in the right way the reason
I was laughing was because I was
actually thinking of the wheel analogy
and then you said it yes so that's why I
was smiling but yeah it sounds like so
you're not really inventing if you want
to go with a metaphor a better story
wheel you're giving tentacles so that's
absolutely you're spreading different
okay that makes sense yeah sure
what is churn rate churn rate is how
quickly people get sick of something and
so it's it's you know a kid will play
with a toy for five minutes and then get
sick of it move to something else and
that's churn rate and so the faster the
churn rate the the worse it is because
people get sick your stuff at a much
quicker rate and so you know how you're
flipping through the channels you you
land on it on a show how how long you're
gonna give that before you flip to the
next channel on the radio how long you
going to give a song before you flip to
the next song and so churn rates
typically in a competitive environment
are very high because there's so many
options now I'm just like bouncing from
thing to thing to thing to thing that
thing that thing you think and that that
you know back in the 50s when there was
just radio then people would sit and
listen to one radio station for hours
and just listen to radio dramas and news
and and they wouldn't flip to anything
because there was only one thing that
they could do now with all the stuff
that we have to do all the entertainment
options the oversaturated tsunami of
entertainment that is around us all the
time
churn rates are very high and and that's
bad for creators so we now have to think
of how we create how do we how do we
create a brand that lowers the churn
rate of people how do we keep them
engaged for longer in more meaningful
ways into our brand and our stories and
and that's something very important
because because the longer you can
engage the audience and the longer the
valuable engagement takes place the more
chance you have to then convert them
into a loyal audience member or
ultimately to what I call a brand
evangelists somebody who's not just
watching your stuff but actually helping
market your stuff hey did you see the
new Game of Thrones this week hey you
know you should check out this show you
can go watch this movie because it's
awesome if you can if you can convert
them into that that's where that's the
sweet spot because then when you get
people one loyal to your brand - that
are so loyal that
marketing your brand you start to solve
some that PNA issue we talked about
earlier of having to rely on so much PA
because you've activated your fan base
to do something valuable but you're not
you're never gonna activate the fan base
if they only engage with your stories
for 10 seconds at a time so now we have
to slow that down get them engaged and
and and have that engagement be valuable
and if you can do that then all of a
sudden you've separated yourself in the
marketplace and solve the major problem
in the in the industry which is these
high chirring rate issues so does that
mean we keep our content shorter or give
them breaks well it it's it depends it
depends on your content but the the
thing that the thing that people love
most is story we live in an
entertainment culture and people love
story more than anything else and so
again whereas attention spans may be
seemingly low they they're no longer low
if you can engage them with story if you
have a great story they'll watch it for
ten hours in a row and and that's fine
so so the so a 10 hour binge watch is a
very low churn rate because they're
watching for 10 hours they're turning
off so this is where technique and craft
come into play if you can understand how
to hook them hook them fast give them
new and better things as you go through
the story then all of a sudden you're
starting to lower that churn rate but at
the same time it's how do we create
multiple engagements that you know if
you're if you're operating just a
network television you have one one our
engagement every week and that's it and
so now between 1 your 1 1 our
engagements you have a week in between
right so now if we can start filling
that week with some other things so as a
companion web series like they do on AMC
maybe a digital comic that gives them
more valuable parts of the story that
bridges the gap between episodes what
you do every single time that you have
your audience engage with valuable
content valuable story
then slowly you're going to start to
lower their churn rate until you get
them to the point that they'll watch
your stuff for 10 hours typically they
won't do that at the beginning it's a
process of getting them to that point to
where they'll say okay I'll watch your
stuff for ten hours
I'll watch 60 hours of your content in a
month through a binge watch because
you've you've you've spent the time and
made an investment into me as an
audience member to a point that where
I'm willing to give you this investment
into your brand all right and so and and
the only way to get them to that point
is to have as much and as many valuable
engagements as humanly possible and the
thing that they value most is story so
you it's not just marketing and
promotions that's a big transmedia
misconception that it's all advertising
and marketing it's really still it's the
bestest story based stuff how do I
create story based engagement so like at
the South by South South by Southwest
they had the the show Bates Motel
created a new a replica of the Bates
Motel that you could actually rent out a
room and stay in while you're a South by
Southwest that's cool marketing but it's
not transmedia because it didn't give
you any more of the story because
because what happens is is when it was
time to go for the festival they would
open the door and they would leave the
room they'd come back at night and you
know they've very limited time and in
the room but if for summary is some way
like they took a picture up the wall and
all of a sudden Norman had written a
message behind that picture if they
would take the Gideon's Bible out of the
out of the desk and open up and it's not
a Gideon's Bible at all and there's an
object in there or maybe it's a it's a
journal that's been written by Norman
get given more insight into his
character insight into some storylines
there's creaky floorboards that you
could pop up and the stuff underneath
there like you flip over the mattress
and there's stuff in the mattress maybe
stuff actually hidden inside the
mattress you have to rip open to find if
you can extend the story so in such a
way that the hotel room becomes part of
the story now now what's happened is
you've created longer points of engaged
for that fanbase and that the fans that
are in the room maybe don't even want to
go outside because the whole room is
part of the story that they love
presumably they don't stay in the
basement l unless they watch that Bates
Motel the show or even if they do maybe
it's a mechanism to get them to watch
the show
but you're gonna have a better chance to
get them to watch the show if you start
to seed the story and extend the store
in a really interesting way so maybe you
never watched the show before but based
on this experience that you have and all
these weird little story clues and
interactions that you you discover in
this room now it makes you even you have
a greater chance of checking it out far
beyond just a marketing experience and
so so it's the it's it's the how is how
do we create lots of really valuable
story based engagements for the fan base
and the every single one of those
engagements creates a lower churn rate
and so maybe the churn rates very high
and for somebody that's the the I'm a DD
I'm distracted I like to do hundred
things I never watch long you know
long-form TV I just like watching web
stuff YouTube step all this stuff if you
can just slowly start giving story based
engagement to that audience member and
then you start to lower the turn right
lower the turn rate lower the turn rate
lower the turn rate so eventually you
can get them to a point to say okay I'll
watch your step
stuff for ten hours in a sitting because
you've give you've invested into me so
much already
so make sense it does okay great Houston
what do you talk about regarding log
lines in your current book so I always
like to approach a log line of one be
able to explain the the story that
you're talking about you know your the
the plot of your story needs to be
teased in the log line but at the same
time if you can also take if you can
also set up the larger play and the log
line which primarily is creating a world
and it be able to communicate the story
world in that log line then not only do
you tease the plot but you also teach
the world which is the bigger play and
so so the log line is just the starting
point that
your project has to exist beyond the log
line so your log line is just one story
that's going to take place hopefully in
this in this larger world for multiple
stories take place and cross over and
connect in all these interesting ways
and so if but if you can even approach
your log line with a with an interesting
world attached and embedded in the log
line then that's going to give you
that's going to intrigue people maybe
even more than the plot itself so if you
remember the trailer guy getting Don
LaFontaine he was in a world you know he
would just start his like he's the movie
trailer guy yeah that like would always
do those voiceovers right he would he
service coined that in a world thing
sure and what what he's doing is in a
world he sets up the context of a story
world and then he's going to tell you in
the midst of a trailer what the story is
inside that world so you know in a world
where all where one day a year all crime
is legal we have a family who is being
terrorized by somebody right so that's
like you know that's how to set up the
purge so the the story world of the
purge is a country where one night a
year all crime is legal
interesting story world interesting
concept that's that that is far bigger
than one individual story but if you can
say in a world where all crime is legal
for one night a year then move into your
individual plot now you've intrigued me
based on the plot but you've also
intrigued me because there's a cool
world so me so so it's it's it's a it's
like an establishing shot in the movie
so you know established John in the
movie is if instead of cutting directly
into here where we're doing this
interview we're going to first show the
outside of the entire building and then
move in here so the reason an
establishing shot is as a normal thing
and filmmaking is because the audience
is more comfortable knowing where we are
then moving into something very specific
and this is just the way we like the
humans and
audience with this way we think and
that's what we're comfortable with
because if you just jump directly into a
scene it can be disorienting this is why
you need an establishing shot so I look
at at seating a story world inside of a
log line like having an establishing
shot for your log line so in a world
where all crime is legal for one day out
of a year that's the establishing shot
then we're jumping into the scene which
is your individual plot which you know
you have a husband and wife who who you
know seek to survive the night from a
guy who breaks in their house right so
so that so it's it's an interesting
thing of like how do we create big
concepts from the from the beginning how
do we create the big IP but then
ultimately we get down to a point where
we need to be able to execute and
communicate it on a very small level so
how do we create Star Wars how do we
create something massive how do we
create something that can sustain for 20
30 40 years but then when I'm talking to
you as a producer or after I'm at a
pitch fest or I'm talking to how do I
boil it down to a line
what because again we need a good story
world and we need a good story how do I
do both in a log line typically a log
line focuses on the story but at the
same time I need the cool story rail but
I don't want to just pitch the story
world without the story because then
then then my products not going to work
so I need both and so I think you craft
a log line in a really interesting way
to do both and it's just a different
type of a process but to approach it but
I think it's always very helpful